You need to be brave, really brave.
And I know, when you think of courageous leaders,...
...you think of those folks who stood implacably and fearlessly,...
...anchored in their sense of rightness,...
...willing to pit their ideas against all comers,...
...against the slings and arrows aimed their way.
Well, I don't think that's brave enough.
I don't think that's good enough for what our shared future will ask of you.
I actually don't think it's ever been good enough.
To let yourself be vulnerable to another point of view...
...that's what takes true courage.
To open yourself to another's convictions,...
...and risk being convinced, a little, or a lot,...
...of the validity of their perspective.
Now that's scary:...
...discovering that someone you vehemently disagree with might have a point,...
...might even be right.
But here's the question.
Do you want to win an argument and feel good about how superior you are?
Or do you actually want to change behaviors and beliefs?
Do you want to win an argument or do you want to change the world?